it's just the place you would have
expected in previous times to have seen
us leadership a global crisis and world
leaders coming together with a response
the idea of this event to coordinate the
search for a vaccine testing and
treatments for covert 19 and to make
sure all are widely available the world
leads these tools and it needs them fast
past experience has taught us that even
when tools are available they had been
not been equally available to all we
cannot allow that to happen a world
filled with 19 requires the most massive
Public Health efforts in history data
must be shared production capacity
prepared resources mobilized communities
engaged and politics set asides I know
we can do it I know we can put people
first leaders spoke from all regions of
the world
technically bringing them all together
was a bit of a challenge can you hear me
no yes yes we can hear you ok
Germany one of four members of the g7
group of countries that will represent
it we're now going to continue to
mobilize all countries of the g7 and the
g20 for them to beg this initiative I
hope that we will be able to reconcile
this initiative with China and the US
because the fight against covert 19 is a
common good for Humanity this shouldn't
be any divisions between countries we
need to join forces to win this battle
the fact that the World Health
Organization was the host of the event
explains why the US didn't take part
president Trump cut all new funding to
the w-h-o because he claimed the global
health body had not been tough enough on
China the WHL failed in this basic duty
and must be held accountable it's a
spokesperson for the US mission to the
UN in Geneva where the w-h-o is based
told Al Jazeera
there'll be no
US official participation we were
informed of this event last week and we
look forward to learning more about this
initiative as soon as possible following
this event the next phase will be led by
the European Union in ten days time
they'll be trying to raise 8 billion
dollars to make sure that vaccines
testing and treatment are available to
everyone James BAE's al Jazeera at the
United Nations dr. johan el buro me is a
professor of medicine at the George
Washington University School of Medicine
she says despite its shortcomings the
World Health Organization's mission is
crucial to tackle a global health crisis
the w-h-o is essential and it has been a
world leader for decades I think that
the crisis of kovat 19 underscores the
importance of having a holistic global
international approach with putting the
best minds from all over the world
together both in the public health
domain the clinical domain and of course
the research domain and that cannot be
separated from issues of poverty of war
even of climate change you must have a
holistic view because these issues are
interconnected the WHS leadership has
while imperfect in some cases but
certainly admirable I completely support
their mission